wir beginnen den überblick über den tag
mit neuen entwicklungen im fall eileen
dem 14 jährigen mädchen das ermordet
wurde der tatverdächtige ist ein
verurteilter sexualstraftäter
sollte wieder in die gesellschaft
eingegliedert werden und schlug dann
mutmaßlich wieder zu ein
29-jähriger unauffällig ein fußball und
ein schlager fan
schlager star annemarie eilfeld und ein
fan 111 ii ein scheinbar alltäglicher
moment für die sängerin doch jetzt lässt
dieser schnappschuss ihr das blut in den
adern gefrieren es ist ein foto mit
alliance mutmaßliche mörder jan p der 29
jährige liebt schalke und schlagermusik
wie die von annemarie eilfeld im mai
2018 kommt er extra zu einer premiere
von alfeld nach berlin und er schafft es
die musikerin zu treffen unfassbar zu
diesem zeitpunkt steht jan p unter
behördlicher beobachtung
mit 14 jahren versucht er ein mädchen zu
vergewaltigen
jan p muss zehn jahre in die psycho
klinik mit anschließender behörden
aufsicht als rückfallgefährdeter
sexualstraftäter nach seinem
klinikaufenthalt zieht jan p in die
hessische gemeinde waldsolms
dort soll er gelebt haben wie ein
student wird gesagt heißt er hatte ein
eigenes zimmer aber ohne eigenes bad und
eigene küche auch der bürgermeister der
gemeinde walter solms ist schockiert von
dem grausamen verbrechen
mutmaßlich begangen von jan p ich hoffe
enkelkinder die eine ist auch fast in
dem alter und ich denke unser mitgefühl
muss jetzt zunächst einmal bei den
eltern den angehörigen
sein von meinen mitarbeiterinnen weiß
ich dass bei ganz normalen
behördengängen wie beantragung
personalausweis absolut freundlich
aufgetreten ist und mir selbst sind auch
keine negativen dinge bekanntgeworden
jan p essverhalten unauffällig nach
bild-informationen
genauso unauffällig wie seine
führungsaufsicht jan p hatte hier wohl
sehr selten besucht worüber man sich im
nachhinein wundert weil eigentlich hätte
er ja regelmäßig von leuten aus der
klinik bzw der behörden aufgesucht
werden sollen wegen der kontrollen im
januar dieses jahres endete am ps
überwachung sechs monate später soll er
ihn im internet geködert nach hessen
verschleppt und ermordet haben
staatsversagen
gewaltprävention trainer karsten stahl
ist überzeugt der tod des jungen
mädchens hätte verhindert werden können
die gesellschaft und menschen müssen wir
ihnen geschützt werden aber wir schaffen
uns unsere täter indem wir nicht
eingreifen weil wir es können und hätte
man prävention bevor menschen zu opfern
und tätern werden und da wird versagt
meine tochter ist jahre alt sie wollte
mein kind schützen muss ich es selbst
schützen zehn jahre psycho klinik und
fünf jahre staatliche überwachung keine
einsicht keine reue keine kontrolle
ungehindert konnte jan p frauen stocken
und womöglich nun eileen zucker töten
und mit annemarie eilfeld sind wir jetzt
verbunden mit der der mutmaßliche mörder
von alina 111 ii gemacht hat wir haben
es vorhin gesehen guten frau eilfeld
guten abend mir gänsehaut am ganzen aber
ja das glaube ich das einfach 55 jahren
als dieses cell 4-endstand können sie
sich erinnern wie der mann damals auch
sie wirkte
er bei mir ist das halt immer so ich bin
normalerweise immer sehr gerne auch mit
fans zusammen und man kennt sich ja nun
auch mittlerweile auch vielen
veranstaltungen ist man immer mal wieder
die gleichen gesichter bei ihm war es so
dass mir der vorher noch nicht
aufgefallen ist den habe ich das erste
mal kennengelernt
nichtsdestotrotz immer so ein bisschen
ins gespräch gekommen also er ist jetzt
relativ freundlich rüber gekommen nur
die fragen die er dann gestellt hat sind
irgendwann halt immer unangenehmer und
immer spezieller geworden und das fand
ich in dem moment komisch und das ist
auch der grund warum ich mich extrem gut
daran erinnern kann ich weiß noch an
welchem tag das war weil ich noch was
ich davor gemacht habe ich weiß was ich
danach gemacht habe und ich an mich
explizit an ihn als person erinnern dass
es wahnsinn das ist wirklich sehr
ungewöhnliche meinen es ist fünf jahre
her sie haben vorhin gesagt jetzt
bekommen sie im nachhinein eine
gänsehaut wie fühlten sie sich damals in
dem moment bei mir war es wahnsinnig
unangenehm das weiß ich halt noch dass
ich an dem tag in berlin mehrere termine
hatte und dann abends so der primäre
gegangen habe es auch wie man in aller
welt gemacht mit den fans geteilt hey
heute abend bin ich am start und ich
schaue mir die primäre von soundso an
und das wird ein toller arm ich freue
mich und da ist es dann halt so dass
wenn manche das mitbekommen sie ihm die
gelegenheit nutzen 111 ii zu machen
vorbeizukommen so ein bisschen da am
roten teppich zu stehen so ein bisschen
unterstützt licht gewitter mitzunehmen
das ist völlig normal und
so war es eben auch bei ihm er war dann
da ich wusste nicht dass er von so weit
her gekommen ist also normalerweise sind
das immer so berliner oder brandenburger
die dann da warten am potsdamer platz
und bei ihm war es dann eben so dass er
spd danach fragte oder mein freund ist
warum der nicht mit dabei ist ob ich
alleine gekommen bin warum er mich
alleine lässt und ob wir überhaupt noch
zusammen sind was mir halt total
unangenehm weil ich das normalerweise
nicht kenne von und meinen zuschauern
und von meinem publikum fans man fragte
hey
aber es war noch nie so dass einer so
penetrant immer wieder nachgefragt das
war mir dann schon ein bisschen
unangenehm
ich habe dann auch das foto gemacht
selber man sieht es glaube ich auch auf
dem c4 dass ich die kamera halte weil er
so gezittert hat und bin ich dann auch
schnell nach unten nachdem das gemacht
und
jetzt dieser schreckliche verdacht und
das muss man noch mal betonen der
mutmaßliche mörder noch ist er nicht
verurteilt aber heute nachmittag vor gut
einer stunde haben sie festgestellt dass
er ihnen auch auf instagram noch folgt
wie fühlen sie sich damit jetzt
wie gut man kann es ja immer nicht
beeinflussen wer ein folgt und was
derjenige diejenige für eine
vergangenheit hat man kann die leute
auch immer unmöglich reingucken
grundsätzlich ist es schon ja gefühl was
jetzt nicht gerade angenehm ist zumal er
auch einige von meinen freunden volk was
ich gesehen habe aus berlin also ich
halte ja irgendwie schon ein bisschen
suspekt finde aber was soll ich was soll
ich sagen also
mir gegenüber hat er sich jetzt in
anführungszeichen freundlich verhalten
zwar sehr penetrant aber zum glück ist
nichts weiter passiert aber letztendlich
macht man sich ja schon seine gedanken
zumal ich auch gerade in der
17 zum beispiel ein stalker hatte
nämlich hat dann bis
es dazu getrieben hat dass ich dann aus
berlin weggezogen bin
vorfeld ganz herzlichen dank dass sie
mit uns offen gesprochen
dann können
[Musik]